[Musique]
à
l'hôte de la verdure ce découlent se
retrouve presque partout à
châlons-sur-marne appelé quelques fois
la petite venise champenoise l'élégante
silhouette de notre dame en vaux cire
fait admirablement sa rivière ses canaux
ses ruisseaux se mélangent se recoupent
s'alimentent mutuellement en traversant
la ville riche de souvenirs historiques
le mot et le nom coule sous des ponts
d'une beauté cachée et parcourt les
promenades du jard véritable écrin de
verdure avec pour toile de fond le
château du marché
les promenades et espaces verts vaste et
bien situé 37 sites est très agréable et
très aéré châlons sur marne ville d'art
et d'histoire mais aussi ville d'eau et
de verdure la physionomie charmeuse
d'une ville de province
fr3 vous salue france région 3 bienvenue
en province à châlons sur marne en
champagne à concevoir à tous et à toutes
et nous allons commencer par un premier
jeu n'est ce pas monsieur points eric
bouin alors vous avez réalisé cet objet
qu'on appelle une fignolant tu as que
l'occasion est pourquoi
voilà la question que nous posons aux
invités de notre avis marc bonnant
pourquoi cette fine yolanthe fabriqués
par monsieur bouin première question à
vous trouver la réponse
non non c'est de la cance rouge très
fier de mes mains est ce que c'est un
genre de gars au nom est ce que ça sert
à frapper quelqu'un rowbury un petit peu
a tracé la frappe est un être humain
oui a frappé à l'être humain c'est une
sorte de six lits
ce fou est quelque chose que les moines
se met pour sedan des pénitents sinon
c'est pour frapper à l'être humain
oui une femme n'ont pas eu du mal un
homme
oui d'accord un homme attend ils en
tiennent une femme aussi une femme ou un
homme aussi parce qu'il me semblait
aimer les femmes ou hommes et ces femmes
ça n'a aucune importance enfin si ça
l'important c'est pour le punir non
[ __ ] anciens annoncé ça moyen de de
torture pas du tout c'est tout à fait ça
ça on peut s'en servir maintenant on se
resserre encore bonbons frappait pour le
plaisir non remarquez on ne frappe pas
très fort médical non plus pour le
plaisir on assiste là il ya des
connaisseurs non ce n'est pas pour le
plaisir on fera pas très fort s'est
posée je sais pas moi c'est pour que
pour faire circuler le sang ah non
celles qui ont frappé on fera pas très
fort il faut attacher
non il faut pas la tâche on frappe
seulement fera pâle mais ça sert à ça
c'est sa sanction
non ce n'est pas pour la défense mais sa
scm et ça fonctionne que pour frapper où
ça rien d'autres usages c'est un usage
symbolique un usage symbolique
je signale quand même que votre chrono
il ya douze minutes tente maintenant il
a sonné oui bah oui depuis que vous
savez qu éventuellement que cette fois
pour le plaisir
bon bah vous allez savoir monsieur pour
200 foire dite neutre
alors éric bouin à quelles raisons
pourquoi avez vous fabriquez donc cette
fine yolanthe expliquez nous alors je
suis d'abord élève à l'école nationale
supérieure des arts et métiers de champs
sur marne et il y à une période
d'initiation
et cette année d'initiation se termine
au bout de deux mois d'entrer à l'école
j'ai fabriqué de mes mains cette fine
yolanthe qui sert à fignoler la tenue
que l'on a
le jour du baptême des premières années
voilà donc la réponse alors attendez
attendez on a maintenant vous le dire
qu'un attendent et en dépendant la
cérémonie je crois je pense savoir qu'à
un moment donné on frappe avec nous
voilà pendant la cérémonie le signe du
baptême
ça se rapproche un peu du glaive du
chevalier arrive où nous faire une
démonstration la voilà on va voir un
petit peu ce que ça donne mireval a
alors attendez imaginons c'est le jour
de votre baptême cher monsieur c'est
mieux voilà prêt regardez bien comme
ceux ci en télé y mettez vous un petit
peu de profil qu'on va bien le mouvement
et comment vous frapper alors allez-y
elle a fait de voir dépêchons nous voilà
il faut quelqu'un qui soit genou donc
bombarder les serveurs web allez-y
regardez bien voilà voilà pourquoi on
frappe
attendez j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
ingénieur un jour alors allez-y
doucement à mon grand voile à cette fine
yolanthe pour nos ingénieurs de l'école
des arts et métiers trois ans d'école et
le diplôme d'ingénieur du frac c'est une
tradition qui est quasiment centenaire
puisque le centenaire sera fêté à
champs-sur-marne l'an prochain merci
messieurs on vous applaudit encore une
fois bravo jean pierre bru marque quand
on frappe encore et bien ça devient
ingénieur des arts est touours inscrire
est tellement mal on est arrêté au mois
de juin
hé les manifs à notre journal fait
remettre de l'ordre nous en paix il se
veut dire jean pierre descombes
pardonnez moi et permettez moi de vous
offrir un moment agréable avec
bernadette lafont oui lequel je remarque
non mais on est là pour jouer mon vieux
faut pas rien alors un monde pour leurs
droits
c'est bien le jeu vous avez demandé
c'est là des questions vous allez poser
bernadette avec un mot de passe quel est
ce mot de passe c'est le mot casserole
alors question avec casseroles
la réponse pour une interrogation faut
trouver le mot correspondants nous
jouant ou soir bernadette vont se voir
comment vous appelez jean-pierre vincent
jean pierre couchez vous avec votre
casserole
oui est ce que vous aimez votre
oui est ce que je pourrai manger votre
casserole
ben je crois que je vous en empêche
frais est ce que votre casserole coûte
cher elle n'a pas de prix votre
casserole et ils vivante et il est n
est-elle drôle de genre votre casserole
oui oui très très près
et ce qu'elle coûte cher votre linge et
johnny avez-vous votre casserole depuis
longtemps depuis toujours
pouvez-vous me faire voir votre
casserole
on n'a pas eu la réponse de berne à tête
je ne sais pas si on a un problème de
son comment sa mère poule
ah bah oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
téléviseur ils étaient états américains
pour ce jeu en coupe les téléviseurs
pour pas qu'on voit le mot la réponse
ben c'est pas grave on me mais c'est
bien monsieur sachez que quand la
casserole et usagers on peut la jeter au
panier et donc je vous demande
maintenant que les cette casserole
pourquoi les carottes sont cuites
moi non plus alors qu'elle était le mot
correspondant aux noms casseroles trois
secondes de réflexion
monsieur attention un deux trois tops et
bien la réponse
il s'agissait de la main mais voilà il
s'agissait demain et oui ce n'est qu'à
l'issue monsieur film sauvez de patients
grâce à grâce aux relations de jean
pierre descombes vous pourrez faire une
grosse bise à bernadette lafont et ça
vaut largement les 100 francs vous
auriez eu autrement sort y est
embarrassé avec ces enfants là il qu'on
ne rien vous fais un lien tandis qu donc
dites moi bernadette ça marche bien le
film avec mocky ça fait un moment qu'il
à l'affiché pack talent
le people un s'abattrait ça va très bien
et vous n'allez pas en tournée un autre
là bientôt si pour l'instant je suis
toujours sur le facteur bon pas très
bien et bien aller sur le pactole c'est
parfait jean pierre descombes
je regarde et je dis ce soir vous êtes
un homme gâté après bernadette regarder
ce que je vous offre ces sommes ne
tiendra pas le mois de juillet 20
heureusement que ça se termine fin
septembre les jeux un jean-pierre la
date n'est pas fixée mon chère maman
tient
nous allons maintenant jouer avec vous
et vous allez jouer ou dira dira pas
c'est à dire qu'on va vous poser
quelques questions et un mot à ne pas
prononcer votre prénom
isabelle isabelle c'était le mot qu'il
ne fallait pas dire aux gens vous restez
l'aller nous jouons au bon allez c'est
parti
il décède en
isabelle vous allez au cinéma
votre souvent qu'est vous allez au
théâtre pas du tout a pas du tout vous
n'allez jamais voir aucun spectacle ah
non jamais vous m'avez jamais vu au
cinéma et télévision cinéma oui dans
quoi je me souviens plus d'études mais
je vous ai déjà vu vous souvenez plus
des titres non bon et qu'elle commence à
dater je regardais à la télévision peut
fort bien sûr ce qu'est ce que vous
regardez comme émission au bas tout ce
qui passe à la télé c'est à dire ben la
variété des filles voila voila vous
c'était ça qui se démentant pas idéal et
décidé d'aller à propos d'un film vous
aussi ça marche bien vous êtes sortis de
pratiquement en même temps que
bernadette est toujours à l'affiché que
notre ami michel galabru et notre ami
molière un oui bon film un très beau
film était michel galabru qui se fait
violer par déguisés en femmes sont
violées par deux suisses est pas mal
mais moi je les ai vus j'ai bien aimé
cette semaine à monsieur attendez
attendez c'est monsieur de alesi dit moi
je me souviens plus du sien monsieur de
pourceaugnac voilà sortir dès qu on
continue
il fallait le dire surtout avant le dira
dira pas et c'est monsieur qui va jouer
votre prénom monsieur joël allez on joue
avec joël monsieur joël toi bonsoir vous
êtes mariés bien sûr oui vous avez une
famille oui bien sûr j'ai trois enfants
ben voilà
c'était 3 ou enfants ne fallait pas dire
d'après vous comment c'était trois
enfants ne fallait pas dire enfin j'ai
tout perdu
et bien ne soyez pas désolé vous est
hypocrite par moment tout semble ok j'ai
perdu monsieur laissant fran soyez
rassurés ne seront pas dans votre poche
ils iront droit dans les caisses des
bonnes oeuvres de la ville de chalon
sûrement nous là quand jean-pierre
d'accord marque
maître capello pardon maître capello est
en place pour l'électronique aux faux
jean-pierre vous avez raté votre starter
voilà bien les rires des jeux de 20
heures
c'est pour vous cher monsieur et les
applaudissements du public
c'est pour vous votre nom votre prénom
le premier jean paul et la définition
avec les trains c'est encore pour vous
elle est donnée par maître capello a et
ce en ferons part bonne réponse d'accord
à six lettres toujours au pluriel
angoisse tourments torture angoisse
tourments torture
inquiète et n'oscille être plurielle
angoisse dorment à tord on pourrait dire
on pourrait dire que c'est pas beau
bravo oui mais voilà on vous offre 100
francs et vous avez là les troènes in
verbe du premier groupe s'il est exposé
dans le détail faire connaître par ici
raconté narré oui bien on arrête pas là
dessus pour autant puisqu'on à la lettre
vous vous proposez aussi l'être
sedin a mammifères dont les doigts sont
terminées par des sabots combres no no
no 3 cl dame redonner à définition se
dit là mammifères dont les doigts sont
terminées par des sabots ongulés au fort
bien w oui déjà vu
importée d'angleterre quatre lettres en
angleterre membre du parti libéral déjà
vues libérales
le w particulier nous le savons c'est
ouais guy bienbienbien t1 i will be no
c'est sûr en quelque sorte ni oui ni non
un électro dit coincé bref c'est la
règle du jeu c'est comme ça monsieur guy
hamilton a brisé les maintenant arrivés
ici
sur le podium les applaudissements d'un
public chaleureux pour le public pour
les téléspectateurs une nouvelle chanson
hugues hamilton
[Musique]
une
tout ça
t
vous mettez
grasset
oh
[Musique]
centre
mais
hommen
et aussi pour ma fille
il
le plus fort
on est là
non
chacune
[Musique]
à
que sans être jeudi
[Musique]
je
au fait c'est qui
sous
son corps pour moi
je suis
elles sont
quand
[Musique]
t
m
[Musique]
mais c'est bien
à
[Musique]
oui
dans
c'est ton jeu maclean
[Musique]
hogan
ans
k
j'étais
elle pleurait
[Musique]
mais toujours le
les deux mille tonnes un chanteur qui
fait le poids et merci mais non merci
tout ce qui nous arrive mon vieux vous
êtes bloqué ou quoi regardez le dans
quel état il est michel boujenah qui
continue moi je flat comme les chanteurs
je voulais faire quelque chose
jean-pierre bons à très bons moments en
perspective n'est ce pas chère madame
nous allons grinder oui avec michel
boujenah l'adjectif c'est pas avec alors
c'est pas un très bon moment en
perspective
bon on va quand même essayer dessins de
poser quelques questions pour découvrir
un adjectif d'accord vous donnez votre
prénom
valérie baleri première question allez-y
bonsoir michel bonsoir
avez vous déjà visiter une cave de
champagne où je suis en plus c'était une
carte de champagne mais c'est d'une cave
j'étais pas seul je souviens même même
avec les bouteilles c'était bien mais
c'est super c'est super c'était bien
dans les cars oui je me souviens dans
les caves c'était bien on étaient
plusieurs c'était bien c'était très bien
c'était très bien vous devriez
d'ailleurs veut venir avec moi que vous
faites après vous trouvez aussi blâmé
plus vilain que décombres
comment connaissez-vous le procédé de
framix de fabrication du champagne jeu
que je ne connais pas le bon procédé
fabrication de champagne mais si vous
voulez m'expliquer simple aime bien ça
me plairait bien
avec fanny aussi on ne viendra tous les
deux oui vous avez une autre question
est ce la première fois que vous venez
dans notre ville oui ça me plaît parce
que les femmes sont belles issia sont
belles les femmes elles sont belles
besson belle
dommage qu'à menant aussi monstrueux oui
mais les femmes elles sont belles
les femmes oui aimez-vous la potée
champenoise oui du moment que c'est une
femme qui me sert la potée champenoise
ça j'aime bien j'aime bien tous les
plats mais surtout la potée du moment
qu'il ya une femme qui me servent la
beauté et qu'après il reste avec moi
évidemment vous voulez bien vous savez
une potée est resté avec moi après abba
sport préféré vous le moyen de transport
que je préfère je m'en tape du bo banque
est une femme avait manqué le train
l'avion la bicyclette du moment qu à une
femme avec moi ça c'est bien
quel est votre style musical mon style
musical c'est plutôt yahoo il y avait
une chanson de gainsbourg qui faisait
lever
une
aimez vous voyagez ja pouvoir chercher
j'adore
plus il ya de femmes dans l'avion mieux
c'est dans des pays moi j'aimerais
d'arrêt trop tôt un pays où il n'y a pas
d'homme ya que des femmes et moi
j'arrive
c'est ça mon rêve oui voilà
eh bien je dirais pas une autre question
des normes non s'arrête là dessus mais
elle parle tout le temps de vous lancer
je dirais que c'était une satire
ça commence par un haut et au total il
ya six lettres aux s'il est ils étaient
des femmes je vous dédie aussi des
obsédés
voilà maintenant sa voix on sent qu'il
ya des frustrations
évitez quand même le studio passée par
là voilà un fait rare
vous croyez que c'est uniquement la
couleur de l'uniforme qui fait le succès
si vous n'avez que bien la paix il faut
des roses non mais vous monsieur
maintenant plus aucun train de
l'uniforme n'importe quoi vous serez
alors en bien des combes
on n'est pas prêt de reconvoquer
heureusement que je termine enfin
on n'a pas le temps de faire un qui dit
mieux patrick ou non ah bon on a débordé
pour bouger des invalides aux gens
paieraient entre ceux qui t'ont leur
fait de grosses bises bernadette fanni
permettez moi mais ça ne sera pas
boujenah qui vous la fera donc tout va
bien c'est les bouges là en ce jour
bouche de nos avons alors pour voir un
petit bonhomme rouge indique qu'on pense
marc capello je dirais prince en
frappant des bonnes oeuvres de janon
sûrement très bien ton pire des comptes
qui n'est pas du tout comme boujenah
donc obsédé vous à vous dites et avant
je rappelle que nous avons joué avec
l'union et avec champagne dimanche
bonsoir et à bientôt
alors à tous
[Musique]